hello everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and I went
and saw predator obviously I've had this
plastic mask for at least two years now
got her the thirst store and it's been
stored like this that's a poor guy
poor guys a little flat so I have some
unpopular opinions yeah let me first
start off by saying I am a huge fan of
the predator films I remember seeing the
first alien film became completely
obsessed with alien and then found
predator through the alien vs. predator
her movies and then went on to just
watch the the predator films so I was
excited about this movie I know a lot of
people were also very excited about it I
posted on Twitter that I was going to
watch this for this episode and everyone
was so upset about how it turned out who
saw it it doesn't seem like anyone
enjoyed predator at all and I had a
really good time with it
are you a predator of my heart did you
like predator he didn't I am so glad
that I enjoyed it it's like obviously
what a cool thing to go into a film
where everyone has said that you're not
going to enjoy it and then enjoy it
that's fun right I am a little concerned
that everyone's going to be super
disappointed and pissed at me but I
really I just really get tired with it
it's completely different than the
original predator films it acknowledges
them
and it moves on in a completely
different direction that I personally
found to really fun a lot of people
aren't enjoying the characters and like
the guy gang and that go out and you
know take take down the Predators I
really liked them I thought they they
had a good chemistry and they had a lot
of charisma and were really funny I
laughed out loud in like a lot of a lot
of moments whole time is just gonna be
me apologizing for enjoying this movie
the vibe I'm getting is that people just
it was a really big change people didn't
like that
I like when franchises change when movie
franchises can like change and update
and I don't know we had a really good
time there was only one other person in
my theater and so I think I might be the
one person alive who actually enjoyed it
but I thought the action was fun enough
the script was fun enough the acting
really sold it like I think the actors
were great and they did a really good
job
I wish there would have been more action
more suspense but I really didn't hate
the comedy I know that a lot of people
are really hating the comedy I always
love comedy when it's added to things
I love these new superhero Marvel films
that are super funny and I really enjoy
when things are inserted with just a ton
of comedy I know it's not necessary and
I know a lot of people will argue like
every character doesn't need to be like
this funny witty like perfect stud of a
human and I definitely agree with that
but I don't know it it didn't fall flat
for me I see bridge with it I would just
apologize through everything I'd say the
only actors that I didn't believe were
too young actors who played bullies who
were bullying our arguably lead
character and
I think the only storyline that I really
didn't believe in it as well is this kid
kind of going along with the ride so the
story is about this soldier named Creed
II and his son his son is on the autism
spectrum and there's actually there's a
lot of there's someone on the autism
spectrum there's ADHD there's Tourette's
there's a lot of mental health dealings
here it's interesting I don't know I
don't know how accurate all of these
things being portrayed were son gets
ahold of predator armor though and
summons predator to earth and is
responsible for all of the happenings
going on you know to sum it up I guess
the son is on the spectrum and doesn't
handle certain things well but really
handles like just being in the midst of
of all of this super well and it felts
like for what they set him up as felt
like that wasn't very consistent I
really hate the brilliant child trope
psycho he figured it all out no time at
all and you know he's just so smart but
he's a little odd it's like okay we get
it
I've seen this that was a little
overdone I'd say his performance was
okay I didn't like the relationship with
him and the mom and the dad I thought
that like the marriage especially was
pretty wonky and dumb I really enjoyed
the friends that McCready meets along
the way I hope they were a fun ragtag
group of like ex-soldiers keegan-michael
key
and Thomas Jane were my two favorite in
that group I thought they were great and
I when I first saw key I was like no
like he's a little like too recognizable
in his comedy for me in my mind that
like I thought it was gonna take me out
of it
I really enjoyed his character oh it's
got a 34 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
but 82% of people liked it okay so I'm
not the only one who likes this movie
that's great I
I've said shit taste in movies though so
there were a few nods to the first two
though and it really made me want to
come home and just watch the first two
which I may do tonight which is like a
good thing I think for a sequel to do
get to the choppers it's a line it's
pretty great one instance of comedy that
I think took it too far too stupid and
just I could see really upsetting some
people just kind of earth to me but I
bet people were fuming when they saw
this is one of the predators chops off
someone's arm and the guy driving the
car doesn't know that the Predators on
board it's like is everything okay and
the predator pushes the arm forward and
it gives a thumbs up that was kind of
disappointing
that's the only moment though that I was
like oh my god the comedy I really liked
the comedy you guys I'm sorry overall I
don't know it kept my attention I
thought it was funny that was funny
I thought the cast did a really good job
with what could have been a stinker of a
script it there's a lot of things that
I've seen before a lot of used tropes
not enough action not enough suspense
but it worked for me for sure I really
think that people are going to hate this
episode of tim has never seen though
because on Twitter I'm just gonna read a
few of these tweets that I got from
people who really really hated the
predator Oh Olivia Munn
I loved Olivia Munn she's great
definitely don't waste your time and
money on the predator as a lifelong
predator fan it was disappointing and
disrespectful
people are like offended by it please
don't make her go see predator people
that's just a mean thing to do don't
torture yourself by seeing the predator
I'm gonna say something that I think
people are gonna get a little softer yet
it's just my opinion it's probably
another video to say you're not either
but
how do I say this
think think some of you some fans of
certain things hold up this original
thing so high in their mind and if it's
at all different like the last Jedi like
this it's immediately terrible I know
like I'm obviously critics are saying
that this is terrible - it's not like
you know just some angry you know fan
humans down in their basements you know
I realized that I'm probably the one
who's skewed on this movie for sure
am i way off base here or do you think
maybe it's possible that you guys didn't
like love it because it was just
different
or am i way off a I don't know that's
kind of the vibe I'm getting but that's
only because I did enjoy it so I like
I'm having a hard time to see that
anyway anyways changing the subject
before I get thrown off of the internet
completely thank you so much for
watching
[Music]
I could you want to wear this you want
to wear this but he doesn't
thank you so much for watching I will
see you all next week with a new episode
[Music]